una primera cita importante para joe
biden el presidente electo anunció el
miércoles que el ron klein un antiguo
asistente y asesor de campaña será su
jefe de gabinete en un comunicado bailén
escribió a klein como invaluable ya que
la administración entrante tiene un
difícil camino por delante su profunda y
variada experiencia y su capacidad para
trabajar con personas de todo el
espectro político es precisamente lo que
necesito en un jefe de gabinete de la
casa blanca mientras enfrentamos este
momento de crisis y unimos a nuestro
país nuevamente klein es un político
experimentado estuvo a cargo de liderar
la respuesta de barack obama a la crisis
de salud del ébola en 2014 ahora se
espera que sea una figura clave en la
lucha contra la pandemia del coronavirus
desde que fue declarado ganador el
sábado va a ir en ha estado ansioso por
ponerse a trabajar a medida que avanza
con su transición estableciendo un grupo
de trabajo sobre el coronavirus
investigando a los posibles miembros de
su gabinete y pronunciando discursos
sobre futuras políticas el miércoles
participó en una ceremonia del día de
los veteranos en filadelfia
trump asistió un evento
fuera de washington su primera aparición
pública oficial desde la votación del 3
de noviembre el presidente ha desafiado
continuamente los resultados de las
elecciones presentando otra demanda en
michigan y haciendo afirmaciones falsas
de fraude generalizado en los últimos
días
bailén ha enfatizado en que nada podría
detener la transición de poder se espera
que su posesión tenga lugar el 20 de
enero